our view of growth and the business
world has really grown up over the last
50 years in this country coming after
World War Two and a period of great
productivity great growth rising living
standards and the United States becoming
really the dominant economy in the world
and all of that plus our cultural
history of entrepreneurialism
individualism has fueled a group of
beliefs about growth in our society
those beliefs are all growth is good
bigger is always better businesses must
grow or die and in the public markets
public companies must grow continuously
in a linear fashion with ever-increasing
quarterly returns unfortunately those
four beliefs are not based in any
science any empirical data or business
reality they are at best half-truths and
some are pure fiction too much growth
can be bad in order to grow a small
business it takes more people more
processes more controls growth has to be
managed growth has to be paced you need
processes for growth you need controls
for growth you need people for growth
and growing a small business is managing
all of that so you don't lose control of
the business bigger is not always better
the bigger an entity the more complex it
is to manage the bigger you become it
puts you into a different competitive
spaces and therefore you have bigger and
better competition
stay in business you don't have to grow
what you have to do is constantly
improve your customer value proposition
better than the competition business is
no different than basically that old
joke about the two guys walking in the
woods who come across the bear and one
guy looks at the other guy and says we
got to outrun the bear and the other guy
says no we don't I just got outrun you
that is business
you just have to out-compete the
competition and deliver more value and
continuously improve to the customer
companies that grow in a continuous
manner for four years or more are rare
or the exception the longer the term if
you go out seven years or ten years it's
very rare growth is not a continuous
linear mechanistic deterministic
function and so the research shows that
what we believe about growth is is
basically completely wrong